Bonjour à tous,
aujourd'hui on va parler
du "Paradoxe des jumeaux".
Le paradoxe des jumeaux c'est un sujet
qui a fait couler beaucoup d'encre.
Il faut dire que c'est à la fois
un des résultats les plus connus
de la Théorie de la Relativité et,
en même temps, un des plus mal compris.
J'imagine que vous en avez déjà entendu
parler.
Prenez deux jumeaux âgés de 20 ans
et imaginez que l'un des deux
embarque dans une fusée très rapide,
disons les deux tiers de la vitesse
de la lumière,
et mette le cap vers une destination
lointaine comme Proxima du Centaure,
l'étoile située à 4 années-lumière
de nous.
Une fois arrivée sur place la fusée fait
demi-tour et revient sur Terre.
Du point de vue du jumeau resté sur Terre
l'aller-retour aura duré 12 ans,
il a donc 32 ans.
Mais le jumeau qui a voyagé
dans la fusée,
lui n'aura vu passer que 9 ans.
Au moment des retrouvailles,
il aura donc seulement 29 ans,
trois années de moins que son frère,
et notez bien qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'un phénomène biologique
de modification du vieillissement,
une horloge à bord de la fusée
indiquera elle aussi
que le voyage aller-retour
n'aura duré que 9 ans.
Ce résultat étonnant est un classique
en relativité restreinte
et on le résume souvent avec des expressions
un peu ambigües comme:
"quand on va vite, le temps se dilate"
ou encore "le temps passe plus lentement"
ou pire "quand on va vite, le temps
se ralentit".
Alors, outre le fait que le phénomène paraît
déjà difficile à avaler,
vous sentez peut-être qu'il y a un problème
avec les formulations de ce genre.
Qu'est ce que ça peut vouloir dire que
"le temps se ralentit quand on va vite"?
Pour faire la lumière sur tout ça,
on va voir en détail
ce qui se passe dans cette expérience
de pensée,
pourquoi certains ont cru qu'il s'agissait
d'un paradoxe,
et pourquoi en définitive il n'y a
rien de paradoxal.
[Générique]
Pour commencer voyons rapidement
les principes de base de la relativité
restreinte.
Je ne vais pas tout détailler,
j'ai déjà fait une vidéo assez
complète sur le sujet
mais on va voir l'essentiel.
Une des idées centrales de cette théorie
c'est qu'en relativité restreinte
le temps et l'espace ne sont plus deux
concepts distincts et indépendants,
ils sont beaucoup plus entremêlées que dans
la physique de Newton et Galilée,
celle qu'on apprend au lycée.
En relativité on considère la notion
d'espace-temps
et on représente souvent cela
de cette manière:
il y à la dimension de temps et
les dimensions d'espace.
Pour des raisons pratiques on ne va
représenter aujourd'hui
qu'une seule dimension d'espace
comme si on vivait sur une droite
au lieu d'un espace à trois dimensions.
Avec cette représentation l'espace-temps
n'a que deux dimensions
mais vous allez voir que ça va
nous suffire.
Un point de l'espace-temps,
par exemple celui ci:
on appelle cela un événement,
ben oui un événement ça se produit
à un endroit précis, à un moment précis,
c'est donc un point de l'espace temps.
Par exemple si je frappe dans mes mains
c'est un événement,
pareil si je décide d'ouvrir
une bouteille de champagne,
ce sont des points précis de l'espace-temps.
Pour se repérer dans l'espace-temps
c'est comme pour se repérer dans l'espace,
c'est pratique de pouvoir utiliser
des coordonnées,
si vous jouez à la bataille navale vous
vous repérez grâce à une grille
qui permet de localiser les positions,
si vous prenez la surface de la Terre
vous pouvez y repérer
n'importe quel lieu grâce à la latitude
et la longitude.
Ces grilles constituent ce qu'on
appelle un système de coordonnées,
eh bien dans l'espace-temps c'est pareil,
pour repérer les événements et pour
pouvoir leur attribuer des nombres
on a besoin d'un système de coordonnées.
Alors en théorie on peut imaginer
plein de façons de le faire
mais il y en a une qui est assez naturelle,
c'est d'utiliser ce qu'on appelle
un référentiel.
Imaginez, pour commencer, que vous ayez
simplement besoin
de repérer des positions autour
de vous dans l'espace.
Une manière de procéder ce serait de
vous trimballer
avec une grille rigide tout autour de vous,
munie de graduations
et de l'utiliser pour mesurer les positions
des choses qui vous entourent.
Maintenant si en plus, en chaque point
de cette grille vous attachez une horloge,
cela va vous permettre précisément
d'attribuer des coordonnées
à n'importe quel événement de l'espace-temps.
Si un événement se produit, vous regardez
en quel point de la grille il a eu lieu
et le temps qu'indique l'horloge située
à cet endroit, à ce moment-là.
Puisque cela permet de mettre des coordonnées
d'espace-temps à chaque événement,
un référentiel de ce genre, constitué
d'une grille spatiale
et d'horloges en chaque point,
eh bien on peut le voir comme une grille
de l'espace-temps
et c'est cette représentation qu'on utilisera
dans la suite.
Notez bien qu'un référentiel c'est, en fait,
une construction abstraite,
qu'on peut considérer comme infinie,
il existe partout à la fois
et ça permet de mesurer des événements,
même situés très loin du point d'origine.
D'ailleurs, même si on imagine souvent le
référentiel comme lié à un objet physique
auquel serait attachée cette grille,
en fait on n'en a pas vraiment besoin.
Des référentiels de ce genre
pour se repérer
dans l'espace-temps, on peut
en imaginer plein.
Ils peuvent notamment être décalés ou
en mouvement les uns par rapport aux autres,
mais la théorie de la relativité restreinte
nous spécifie deux choses importantes.
La première c'est qu'il existe des
référentiels particuliers, privilégiés,
qu'on appelle "les référentiels inertiels".
Ce sont les référentiels dans lesquels
les objets qui ne subissent aucune force
sont immobiles
ou bien vont en ligne droite,
à vitesse constante,
ce qu'on appelle la fameuse
"translation rectiligne uniforme",
et justement, si vous prenez deux référentiels
inertiels, ils seront toujours,
forcément en translation rectiligne uniforme
l'un par rapport à l'autre.
Cette idée qu'il existe des référentiels
inertiels
qui seraient spéciaux en quelque sorte,
elle n'est pas spécifique de la relativité
restreinte,
on utilisait déjà ces référentiels pour
la relativité au sens de Galilée,
on les appelait d'ailleurs souvent
"les référentiels galiléens",
mais ce qui change en relativité restreinte,
c'est que
dans tous ces référentiels inertiels
la lumière va à la même vitesse.
La vitesse de la lumière est
constante, absolue
et indépendante du référentiel inertiel.
Alors ça, à la base c'est une observation,
un truc qu'on a constaté expérimentalement
et c'est quelque chose d'impossible
à intégrer
dans la physique de Newton et Galilée
et c'est à cause de ça qu'il a fallu créer
la relativité restreinte.
En particulier pour satisfaire ce caractère
absolu de la vitesse de la lumière,
il a fallu abandonner des principes qui nous
étaient très naturels et intuitifs.
Ainsi par exemple, en relativité restreinte
les durées mesurées ne sont plus absolues,
si vous prenez deux événements
de l'espace-temps
et que vous mesurez l'écart de temps
qui les sépare,
la valeur obtenue va dépendre du référentiel
dans lequel on a fait la mesure.
Cette relativité des durées, c'est une idée
assez difficile à accepter mais,
à mon avis, elle a une conséquence encore
plus perturbante:
en relativité restreinte il n'y a plus
de notion absolue de simultanéité.
Vous savez, dans notre intuition quotidienne,
on parle souvent du présent par opposition
au passé et à l'avenir,
comme si la notion de présent,
de "en ce moment" avait un sens absolu,
eh bien pas en relativité restreinte.
Se demander ce qu'il se passe
"maintenant, en ce moment"
par exemple sur Mars ou Pluton, eh bien
ça n'a pas de sens bien défini,
On en reparlera, mais pour l'instant
revenons à nos jumeaux.
Pour essayer d'y voir clair dans ce paradoxe,
que j'ai évoqué au début de la vidéo,
on va réaliser des diagrammes d'espace-temps.
Représentons donc notre espace-temps
avec seulement deux dimensions,
et pour pouvoir mettre des coordonnées
aux évènements qui s'y produisent,
on va utiliser un référentiel,
qu'on présente comme une grille, un
quadrillage de l'espace-temps.
On va imaginer que ce référentiel
est celui attaché à la Terre,
le référentiel terrestre.
Ça n'est évidemment pas le seul choix
possible,
on aurait pu en prendre d'autres
et c'est ce qu'on fera plus tard.
Un objet qui se déplace dans l'espace
apparaîtra comme une courbe
dans ce diagramme, cette courbe traduit
l'évolution de la position de l'objet
au fur et à mesure que le temps passe, on
appelle cela sa "ligne d'univers".
Prenons par exemple le jumeau qui reste
sur Terre,
puisqu'on s'est placé dans
le référentiel terrestre,
eh bien il reste tout le temps
au même endroit
au fur et à mesure que le temps passe
et sa ligne d'univers est celle ci.
De façon générale un objet immobile, dans
le référentiel qu'on a choisi,
sera toujours représenté par une ligne
d'univers verticale,
un objet qui va à vitesse constante
dans le référentiel
sera représenté par une droite plus ou
moins inclinée,
et d'autant plus inclinée que la vitesse
est importante.
Alors un cas particulier ce sont les lignes
qui représentent les trajectoires
des rayons lumineux, puisque rien ne peut
aller plus vite qu'un rayon lumineux
cela représente la pente maximum atteignable
par la ligne d'univers d'un objet.
Et donc pour faire simple, on va choisir les
unités du graphique
pour que ces lignes soient à 45 degrés.
Par exemple si on gradue l'axe vertical
du temps en années
et l'axe horizontal de l'espace
en années-lumière.
Le trajet d'un rayon lumineux partant de
l'origine sera représenté par une diagonale.
Et enfin pour finir, dans un diagramme
de ce genre
chaque ligne horizontale représente
une ligne de simultanéité du référentiel
il s'agit de l'ensemble des événements
qui ont lieu simultanément
au même moment dans
le référentiel considéré.
Détail important, ce ne sont pas des
lignes d'univers,
puisque aucun objet physique ne peut avoir
cette trajectoire,
elles servent juste à repérer les moments
simultanés de ce référentiel.
Bien, voyons maintenant ce qu'il arrive
au deuxième jumeaux.
Imaginons que le point d'origine
du référentiel représente
l'événement du décollage de la fusée,
la séparation des jumeaux.
Pour celui qui va vers Proxima du Centaure
aux 2/3 de la vitesse de la lumière,
eh bien voici la ligne d'univers qu'on
aura:
Proxima étant à environ
quatre années-lumière,
l'événement qui marque son arrivée
aux abords de l'étoile sera celui ci:
Dans le référentiel du jumeau terrestre,
cela se produira au bout de six ans.
Jusqu'ici tout va bien, mais on l'a dit
en relativité restreinte, la notion
de durée entre deux événements
n'est plus absolue, elle dépend
du référentiel.
Là on a calculé qu'entre le décollage et
l'arrivée à Proxima
il s'était écoulé 6 ans dans
le référentiel terrestre.
Mais combien de temps s'est-il écoulé
dans le référentiel du deuxième jumeau,
celui de la fusée?
C'est quelque chose qu'on peut calculer
assez facilement
avec les principes de la relativité.
Ça n'a rien de très compliqué et pour
ceux que ça intéresse,
je vous écris le calcul et vous pouvez
mettre "pause".
Pour les autres je vous donne la réponse:
pour le jumeau de la fusée il ne s'est écoulé
qu'environ 4 ans ½… pas 6 ans!
Souvent pour désigner cette différence
entre les mesures
de la durée qui sépare deux événements,
on parle de la dilatation du temps,
alors le terme n'est pas idéal et peut
mener à des confusions.
Retenez plutôt qu'il s'agit de la
relativité des durées.
Je répète: la durée qui sépare deux
événements dépend du référentiel,
ici entre le décollage et l'arrivée
vers Proxima:
6 ans dans le référentiel terrestre,
4,5 ans dans le référentiel de la fusée.
Cet effet de la relativité des durées ça
n'est pas un artefact de calcul,
il est parfaitement réel
et on peut le mettre en évidence
expérimentalement dans certaines situations.
On le voit très bien notamment avec
des particules qu'on appelle les muons.
Les muons ce sont des sortes de cousins
des électrons
et ils sont parfois produits lors
des collisions des rayons cosmiques
avec les molécules de l'atmosphère,
quand un muon est créé de cette façon,
il possède généralement par rapport
à l'atmosphère de la Terre
une vitesse très proche de celle
de la lumière.
En revanche sa durée de vie est très limitée
puisqu'on sait
qu'un muon se désintègre systématiquement
au bout d'environ 2 microsecondes.
Sauf que, depuis la surface de la terre,
avec nos détecteurs,
on observe en permanence des muons
qui semblent être restés en vie
bien plus longtemps que ça et avoir fait
presque dix fois plus de chemin.
Alors cela peut paraître étonnant
mais ça s'explique parfaitement
avec le phénomène de relativité des durées.
Dans le référentiel du muon
le temps qui s'écoule
entre les deux événements que sont
sa création et sa désintégration,
ce temps c'est seulement 2 microsecondes,
mais vu de la terre, dans le référentiel
terrestre,
donc à cause de la vitesse relative proche
de celle de la lumière,
la durée qui s'écoule est environ dix
fois plus importante.
La durée entre deux événements est
relative.
Alors reprenons nos jumeaux,
le premier vient d'arriver aux abords
de Proxima du Centaure,
son horloge de bord indique
quatre ans et demi
et il décide de faire demi-tour
pour retourner vers la Terre,
et là, il se passe exactement
la même chose,
son voyage retour durera également
4,5 ans de son point de vue à lui,
et dans le référentiel terrestre,
cela sera à nouveau 6 ans.
Quand les deux jumeaux se retrouvent,
le jumeau terrestre aura donc
vu défiler 12 ans
et celui de la fusée seulement 9 ans,
il aura moins vieilli, il aura 29 ans,
tandis que l'autre en aura 32.
Alors formulé comme ça c'est différent
et plus perturbant que mon histoire de muon,
ça n'est pas juste une mesure faite
de deux points de vue différents,
là, on peut au même endroit, au même
moment constater
que l'un des jumeaux a vieilli
moins que l'autre
et je répète, rien à voir avec un phénomène
biologique,
pour lui il s'est écoulé moins de temps
que pour l'autre
et cet écart de temps dépend de la vitesse
de la fusée,
plus la fusée va vite, plus, en proportion,
l'écart sera important.
En allant à 99 % de la vitesse
de la lumière,
le voyage aller-retour aurait pris
environ 8 ans pour le jumeau terrestre
et seulement un an pour celui de la fusée.
C'est super intrigant mais si on fait
une analogie
avec les mesures de distance dans l'espace
on peut y voir un peu plus clair.
Prenez deux points sur une carte,
cela ne vous surprend pas si je vous dis
que la distance
qui sépare ces deux points dépend du chemin
choisi pour les relier.
Il y a des chemins plus courts,
qui ont moins de kilomètres,
et d'autres plus longs,
et il y en a même un
qui en principe est le plus court possible.
Si on prend deux événements
de l'espace-temps,
la séparation et les retrouvailles
des jumeaux
et qu'on considère des lignes d'univers
qui relient ces deux événements
le temps écoulé le long d'une ligne d'univers
dépend du chemin suivi.
Cette mesure de temps le long
d'une ligne d'univers,
c'est un concept très important
de la relativité
qu'on appelle "le temps propre".
À toute trajectoire dans l'espace-temps
on peut associer un temps propre
et, entre deux événements donnés, le temps
propre dépend de la trajectoire suivie.
Et notez bien, on ne peut pas dire
que ce soit parce que le temps se ralentit
ou que les secondes s'allongent,
quand un chemin sur une carte est plus
long qu'un autre
ça n'est pas que les kilomètres
sont plus grands
ou que les roue de votre vélo deviennent
soudainement plus petites,
il y a plus de distance à franchir,
c'est tout.
Eh bien là, de même, c'est juste
qu'il y a en quelque sorte
moins de temps à franchir pour relier
les deux événements
par la ligne d'univers du jumeau
de la fusée
que par celle du jumeau terrestre.
Avec ce raisonnement vous remarquerez
quand même
qu'il y a quelque chose de contre-intuitif:
le chemin qui correspond au temps le plus
court est celui
qui paraît visuellement le plus long
dans le diagramme et réciproquement.
Eh bien c'est parce que le temps, c'est
certes une dimension supplémentaire,
mais ça n'est pas la même chose
que l'espace,
et donc ce diagramme d'espace-temps ne
s'interprète pas comme une carte classique.
D'ailleurs pour ceux qui ont mis pause
tout à l'heure
c'est lié au signe "moins" qui apparaît
dans le pseudo-théorème de Pythagore.
Bien, donc en résumé, si on admet
les règles de la relativité restreinte,
cette histoire de jumeaux qui vieillit
moins que l'autre est assez perturbante
mais pas forcément de quoi appeler ça
un paradoxe.
D'ailleurs quand cette expérience de
pensée a été imaginée
pour la première fois en 1911
par Paul Langevin
sur une idée originale d'Einstein,
eh bien elle n'a pas été présentée
comme un paradoxe.
Et pourtant il y a un truc bizarre,
à première vue on dirait
que c'est vraiment la vitesse du jumeau
de la fusée qui limite son vieillissement,
et plus il ira vite moins il vieillira.
Et pourtant on le sait, la vitesse c'est un
truc relatif,
le jumeau de la terre se considère
comme immobile
et voit la fusée s'éloigner lui à 200 000
kilomètres par seconde,
mais réciproquement, celui de la fusée peut
très bien considérer
que c'est lui qui est immobile et que c'est
la Terre qui s'éloigne à 200 000 km/s.
Donc, du point de vue de la fusée,
c'est le jumeau de la Terre qui devrait moins
vieillir.
Et là c'est très bizarre parce que si
la situation est effectivement
symétrique entre les deux jumeaux,
comment est ce que l'un peut vieillir
moins que l'autre?
Il devrait pas y avoir de différence
entre les deux!
Et c'est en ça que le paradoxe des jumeaux
est un paradoxe.
Cette objection avait déjà été formulée
assez tôt,
dans les années 1920 par des physiciens
comme Painlevé
où le philosophe Henri Bergson,
et pourtant, quand on y regarde de plus près,
il n'y a pas de paradoxe
car la situation n'est pas symétrique
entre les deux jumeaux.
Pour vous le montrer, un petit rappel.
En relativité il existe des référentiels
particuliers, les référentiels inertiels,
et ici ce sont bien des référentiels
supposés inertiels qu'on a utilisées,
mais il y a une entourloupe.
Le premier jumeau, celui qui est resté
sur Terre
est dans le même référentiel inertiel
tout au long de l'expérience,
le référentiel de la Terre.
Mais le deuxième jumeau, celui de la fusée,
doit faire demi-tour au milieu,
il change de référentiel en faisant ça,
ce jumeau est inertiel sur chacun
des deux segments du voyage,
mais il n'est pas inertiel sur l'ensemble
de la trajectoire.
Une autre manière de voir ce changement
de référentiel inertiel
c'est de dire que, pour faire son demi-tour,
la fusée doit subir une décélération,
puis une accélération dans l'autre sens,
alors que le jumeau terrestre lui, ne
subit rien du tout,
à aucun moment, donc la situation
des deux jumeaux n'est pas symétrique,
et par conséquent il n'y a rien de paradoxal
a affirmer que l'un puisse être
plus jeune que l'autre lors
des retrouvailles.
Le point clé de la résolution du paradoxe
c'est qu'en relativité restreinte
les vitesses sont relatives,
on ne peut pas définir de notion
absolue de vitesse.
Mais on peut définir une notion absolue
d'accélération,
la fusée subit vraiment une accélération
et elle la subit dans tous les référentiels
inertiels.
Alors admettons, le jumeau de la fusée
va moins vieillir que l'autre
et, présenté comme ça, c'est assez
tentant de dire
que c'est du coup plutôt l'accélération
elle-même qui est responsable du phénomène,
et c'est assez bizarre parce que,
du coup, on peut se demander
à quel moment l'écart se creuse vraiment
entre les deux jumeaux,
c'est juste au moment du demi-tour?
Faisons une très légère variante de
l'expérience de pensée,
reprenons le jumeau de la fusée mais
imaginons qu'en faisant son voyage
il n'ait pas encore vraiment décidé
s'il allait faire demi-tour ou pas.
Il arrive en vue de Proxima et on sait
qu'il a mis 4 ans et demi
de son point de vue à lui.
Et pourtant, s'il n'a pas encore
fait demi-tour,
ben il est inertiel depuis le début
et donc, pour l'instant,
la situation est vraiment symétrique.
On envie de penser qu'il devrait avoir 6 ans
comme l'autre,
donc c'est le demi-tour qui le fait
soudainement rajeunir?
Eh bien, pour lever l'ambiguïté, il faut
se souvenir d'un truc primordial:
en relativité il n'y a plus de notion
absolue de simultanéité.
C'est super important, dire que deux
événements distincts sont simultanés
c'est relatif aux référentiels.
Pour matérialiser le truc, imaginons
que suite au départ de la fusée
chacun des deux jumeaux ouvre chaque année
une bouteille de champagne pour marquer
l'anniversaire.
Ça nous fait des événements précis qui
se trouvent là sur les lignes d'univers.
Demandons-nous maintenant ce qu'il se
passe sur Terre
au moment où la fusée atteint
Proxima du Centaure.
Du point de vue du jumeau terrestre
c'est facile,
on l'a dit les lignes de simultanéité
sont comme ça,
et donc au moment où la fusée
atteint Proxima,
le jumeau terrestre ouvre sa 6ème
bouteille de champagne, très bien.
Maintenant plaçons-nous du point de vue
du jumeau de la fusée,
quand il arrive à Proxima quels sont les
événements
qui se trouvent sur sa ligne de simultanéité,
les événements qui pour lui ont lieu
"en ce moment"?
Eh bien la ligne de simultanéité
n'est pas la même dans son référentiel,
la simultanéité est une notion relative,
pour trouver les lignes de simultanéité
du référentiel de la fusée
il faut se souvenir d'un truc:
La vitesse de la lumière doit être la
même dans tous les référentiels inertiels,
avec les unités qu'on a choisi,
ça se traduit par le fait
que la "ligne de lumière" doit diviser
en deux
l'angle entre les deux axes d'espace et
de temps,
donc l'axe de temps et les lignes
de simultanéité la fusée sont comme ça:
et celle qui contient l'événement
de l'arrivée à Proxima est celle-ci:
Donc pour le jumeau de la fusée,
l'arrivée à Proxima se fait
au bout de 4,5 ans mais, de son point de
vue à lui, au moment où ça se produit,
le jumeau terrestre n'a ouvert que trois
bouteilles de champagne,
il n'a vécu que trois ans et quelques
et c'est parfaitement logique hein,
tant que le demi-tour n'a pas eu lieu
la situation doit être symétrique
chacun des deux jumeaux estime dans son
référentiel
qu'au moment de l'arrivée à Proxima
c'est l'autre qui est plus jeune.
Mais quand le jumeau de la fusée décide
de faire son demi-tour
et donc de changer de référentiel,
il casse la symétrie.
Dans le nouveau référentiel
qui est le sien
la ligne de simultanéité est différente,
et sur celle-ci le jumeau de la Terre
a quasiment 9 ans,
le changement de référentiel fait varier
instantanément
de presque 6 ans son estimation de l'âge
de l'autre jumeau.
Le trajet retour dure ensuite 4,5 ans
pour lui,
mais il estime que cela correspond à une
durée de 3 ans et quelques seulement
pour le jumeau terrestre.
Et donc de façon cohérente,
lors des retrouvailles
le jumeau terrestre a bien vécu 12 ans
alors que lui seulement 9.
Alors oui je sais c'est dur à accepter
comme calcul
mais tout cela c'est la faute
de notre incapacité
à abandonner l'idée de simultanéité absolue,
c'est vraiment dur de se convaincre
que quand on considère des lieux éloignés
la simultanéité n'a plus de sens absolu.
Et, en particulier, quand le jumeau de la
fusée se demande:
"quel âge à mon frère en ce moment? "
Eh bien la réponse va changer
soudainement de 6 ans
du fait du demi-tour qui le place
dans un autre référentiel.
La conséquence de cela, et
c'est primordial,
c'est que cela n'a pas de sens absolu
de comparer les âges
des deux jumeaux tant qu'on ne les a pas
à nouveau réunis,
tant qu'ils sont en des lieux différents
il n'y a pas de notion absolue de
différence d'âge entre eux
et de "lequel est plus vieux que l'autre? "
Pour les comparer de façon absolue
il faut les réunir au même point
de l'espace-temps, au même événement,
et c'est en cela que l'expérience
de pensée des jumeaux
est un truc conceptuellement plus profond
que ce qu'on appelle, la dilatation
du temps,
et qu'on illustre avec le temps de
vie des muons cosmiques.
Tout ce raisonnement sur les jumeaux
je l'ai effectué
dans un cadre assez spécifique,
la vitesse de la fusée est constante,
puis ont fait demi-tour quasi
instantanément,
et on revient avec la vitesse opposée.
Mais on peut complètement généraliser
à d'autres mouvements.
Si on regarde le diagramme d'espace-temps,
on l'a dit,
les jumeaux suivent deux trajectoires
différentes
qui relient deux événements, la séparation
et les retrouvailles,
mais on peut imaginer tout un tas d'autres
trajectoires
avec des vitesses et des accélérations
variables
qui relient ces deux points de l'espace-temps
et à chacun de ces trajets correspond
un temps propre différent,
pour des trajectoires très accélérées
il pourra même être aussi petit qu'on veut.
Mais dans tous les cas la trajectoire
inertielle,
celle du jumeau terrestre sera toujours celle
qui fournit le temps propre le plus élevé,
on dit qu'elle maximise le temps propre.
Un peu comme, à l'opposé dans l'espace,
sur une carte,
la ligne droite est toujours le chemin
qui minimise la distance.
Le fait que le principe de calcul du
temps propre se généralise
à d'autres mouvements est d'ailleurs
ce qui a permis de tester
le paradoxe des jumeaux dans une véritable
expérience avec des horloges.
Revenons en 1971,
à cette époque le débat sur la question
n'est pas encore totalement terminé,
il y a toujours quelques physiciens
qui ne croient pas
à cette histoire d'horloges qui
ne marqueraient pas le même temps
après avoir suivi des chemins différents.
Alors deux physiciens américains
Hafele et Keating
décident de faire vraiment l'expérience,
évidemment ils ne vont pas partir
dans l'espace, dans une fusée,
pour un voyage de plusieurs années,
mais simplement faire un tour de la terre
en avion.
Ce n'est pas exactement le même calcul
que la trajectoire en ligne droite
du jumeau de la fusée, mais les équations
de la relativité
permettent sans problème de traiter ce cas.
Hafele avec keating font d'abord
le calcul théorique,
où ils estiment l'écart auquel il faut
s'attendre
si on fait voler une horloge autour
de la Terre,
par rapport à une horloge
qui resterait au sol.
Pour un avion volant vers l'est ils prédisent
que l'horloge retardera de 40 nanosecondes,
et pour un avion volant vers l'ouest
elle avancera de 275 nanosecondes.
Alors oui, par rapport au paradoxe
des jumeaux tel qu'on l'a présenté au début
il y a une différence à cause de la
rotation de la Terre.
Du fait que la Terre tourne,
aucune horloge n'est
sur une véritable trajectoire inertielle
pas même l'horloge de référence,
celle qui reste au sol.
L'horloge qui vole vers l'ouest va à
l'encontre de la rotation de la Terre,
donc elle est plus proche d'une vraie
trajectoire inertielle,
on s'attend donc à ce que, pour elle,
l'écoulement du temps ait été plus important.
Pour celle qui va vers l'est, eh bien
c'est l'inverse
et vous voyez que les écarts calculés
ne sont pas énormes,
quelques centaines de nanosecondes
maximum,
mais à l'époque les progrès
des horloges atomiques
permettaient d'espérer une précision
de l'ordre d'une dizaine de nanosecondes,
ce qui rendait possible
de tenter l'expérience.
Alors assez pour la théorie, qu'ont fait
Hafele et Keating pour tester cela?
Eh bien ils ont d'abord demandé
un financement de 8000 $
avec lequel ils ont acheté
huit billets d'avion
pour faire le tour du monde
en plusieurs escales.
Sur chaque vol il y avait deux places
pour eux
et deux places enregistrées au nom
d'un certain Mister Clock.
Il s'agissait en fait de quatre horloges
atomiques.
Ils ont ainsi fait le parcours une fois
dans un sens et une fois dans l'autre,
et à chaque fois ils ont comparé ça avec
des horloges restées au sol.
Et, roulements de tambour…
Voici les écarts qu'ils ont trouvés:
59 nanosecondes en moins pour l'avion
volant vers l'est
et 273 nanosecondes en plus pour celui
volant vers l'ouest.
Pour la première fois de l'Histoire
on faisait une vraie expérience
de paradoxe des jumeaux et on montrait le
phénomène avec des vraies horloges.
Et donc pour 8000 $ seulement ils ont
quand même réussi à tester
l'une des prédictions les plus importantes
et les plus spectaculaires
de la théorie de la relativité.
Évidemment l'expérience de Hafele et Keating
a définitivement mis un terme aux débats,
et aujourd'hui tous les physiciens
reconnaissent bien
que le décalage des horloges
est un phénomène réel.
Selon votre trajectoire, votre temps propre
mesuré entre deux événements
ne sera pas le même.
Alors comme souvent cet effet très étonnant
de la physique
a inspiré des œuvres de fiction.
Une qui est intéressante c'est le roman d
e Joe Haldeman: Forever War,
"la Guerre éternelle" en France
est sorti en 1974.
Dans ce roman l'auteur imagine des soldats
envoyés à l'autre bout de la galaxie
à l'aide d'une nouvelle technologie
afin de combattre des méchants aliens.
L'histoire commence en 1997,
dans le roman,
et le héros retourne sur Terre
après deux ans de combat.
Sauf que s'il ne s'est écoulé que deux
ans pour lui,
27 ans ont passés sur Terre,
qui est maintenant en 2024.
Eh oui, à cause de la différence des
temps propres,
et donc notre héros revient dans un monde
et une société
qui ont complètement changé par rapport
à ce qu'il a connu
et il a bien du mal à s'adapter
à cette nouvelle vie,
ensuite il se passe plein d'autres trucs
et ça recommence même
de façon encore plus importante.
Ce qui est intéressant dans cette
histoire c'est que, dans le roman,
cet effet est utilisé comme une métaphore
de la guerre du Vietnam
et des difficultés de réinsertion sociale
qu'ont connues les soldats américains
à leur retour.
Ça avait été d'ailleurs le cas de Joe
Haldeman, l'auteur.
Une autre œuvre de fiction bien connue
qui exploite le paradoxe des jumeaux,
c'est évidemment le film "Interstellar"
de Christopher Nolan,
avec une légère variante toutefois
puisque dans Interstellar
la principale cause de décalage temporel
c'est le champ gravitationnel.
Eh oui pour l'instant j'ai uniquement
parlé du paradoxe des jumeaux
dans le cadre de la relativité restreinte,
sans la gravité,
mais la prise en compte de celle ci
modifie légèrement la donne.
Plus précisément la théorie de la
relativité générale
nous fait interpréter la gravité comme
une déformation de l'espace-temps,
et sans rentrer dans les calculs
géométriques bourrins,
vous vous doutez que si je déforme
l'espace-temps,
ça va changer les calculs de temps
et de distance.
C'est comme si, sur une carte, je place
soudainement une chaîne de montagnes,
ça va modifier les distances à parcourir
pour aller d'un point à un autre,
eh bien en relativité générale, le temps
propre le long d'une trajectoire
va dépendre de la courbure de l'espace-temps
qu'on va traverser.
Mais attention, ça fonctionne à nouveau
à l'envers
de l'intuition de la carte géographique,
les zones de l'espace temps très courbées
vont donner lieu à des temps propres
plus faibles
et d'ailleurs c'est surtout la courbure
du temps qui provoque cet effet.
Et donc si deux jumeaux se séparent,
que l'un va vivre dans une zone
de plus forte gravité
disons, proche d'un trou noir, et revient
ensuite voir l'autre,
celui qui aura voyagé près du trou noir
aura moins vieilli.
Alors deux choses à ce sujet,
je l'ai occulté tout à l'heure mais dans
l'expérience de Hafele et Keating
avec les avions, cet effet de gravité
jouait aussi un rôle,
le vol des avions se produit en altitude,
donc dans un champ de gravité
plus faible qu'à la surface de la Terre,
ça a bien sûr été pris en compte
dans le calcul.
L'autre chose c'est que cet effet
gravitationnel
on a aussi pu le tester expérimentalement
indépendamment de l'effet cinématique.
En 2010 dans un article publié dans "Science"
des physiciens ont montré
qu'ils avaient mesuré le décalage
de temps propre
entre deux horloges qui étaient espacées
de seulement 33 cm de hauteur.
Comme cette très légère différence
d'altitude induit
une très légère diminution
du champ gravitationnel,
l'horloge située en bas a subi
une courbure plus importante
et donc a moins vieilli que celle du haut.
Et notez que, dans la version générale
de l'effet, avec la gravité,
on retrouve la même idée que dans la
version en relativité restreinte,
c'est la trajectoire inertielle qui
maximise le temps propre,
or, en relativité générale, la trajectoire
inertielle
ça n'est plus la trajectoire rectiligne
uniforme, c'est la chute libre.
Donc si vous prenez deux points de
l'espace-temps,
c'est la trajectoire de chute libre
qui les relie qui semblera la plus longue.
Alors ça a une conséquence amusante,
si vous tombez dans un trou noir,
mieux vaut ne pas se débattre,
une fois passé l'horizon, votre destin
est de toute façon figé,
vous allez finir dans la singularité
du trou noir,
alors autant profiter au maximum
de la descente
en maximisant son temps propre, et pour ça
il faut suivre la trajectoire inertielle,
se laisser tomber!
Si vous vous acharnez a essayer de
ressortir,
en allumant des moteurs ou quoi que ce soit,
d'une part ça ne servira à rien, et en plus
ça diminuera votre temps propre
jusqu'à la singularité, vous vivrez
moins longtemps.
Et donc, le conseil tourisme du jour:
si vous tombez dans un trou noir,
laissez vous faire
et profitez du temps qui vous reste.
Voilà, c'est tout pour aujourd'hui,
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura permis
d'y voir un tout petit peu plus clair
sur cet apparent paradoxe et sur
la bonne manière de le traiter
dans le cadre de la relativité.
Les actus de la chaîne c'est sur
facebook et sur twitter
Abonnez-vous, la cloche tout ça,
et on se retrouve prochainement
pour une nouvelle vidéo.
À bientôt
[Musique]
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -